[Musica]
Beh avete mai fatto Bunch Jumping
l'attività di saltare da un'altezza
pazzesca chiaramente con delle cinture
con imbracatura e di lanciarsi nel vuoto
con un elastico che poi ti fa che tiene
sospeso nel vuoto vedo tanti giovani in
sala alzi la mano chi chi ha mai fatto
questa esperienza Chi ha mai provato a
fare questa attività ah Ottimo nessuno
neanche neanche un dito alzato Ah ecco
Uno c'è uno c'è Beh proviamo a vivere
insieme queste sensazioni proviamo a
immaginarci in cima a un gratacelo in
cima a un ponte di 100 m alto siamo lì
perché abbiamo maturato questa idea da
tempo perché ci abbiamo pensato Abbiamo
cominciato a
leggere
recensioni le esperienze di chi aveva
già fatto bunging
Jumping Abbiamo cominciato a valutare i
pro i contro i rischi
e e poi un giorno ci ritroviamo lì in
cima a quel gratt Cello in Cimo a quel
ponte pronti a saltare nel vuoto e
mentre ci allacciano le cinture ci ci
mettono l'imbracatura ci sentiamo le le
gambe che tremano cominciavo a pensare
ma chi me l'ha fatta fare aspetta un
attimo che ora mi tolgo queste cinture e
me ne vado c'ho provato ma non sono
obbligata a saltare posso andare a casa
nessuno mi mi sta obbligando a farlo Poi
però mentre siamo presi dall'ansia dalla
paura sentiamo il cuore che batte
fortissimo diciamo no però io sono qui
perché ci ho pensato non è che mi sono
svegliato stamattina ho detto che faccio
Oggi mi vado a lanciare da 100 m di
altezza Io sono qui perché è un
obiettivo che voglio raggiungere è un
qualcosa che che voglio fare
e e quindi io prendo il coraggio a due
mani prendo il coraggio a due mani e
Salto Salto e salto nel vuoto salto in
un vuoto che mi fa venire un vuoto allo
stomaco però è subito un senso di
liberazione mi sento subito svuotare
svuotata da tutte le paure svuotata da
tutti quei limiti Da quegli stereotipi
che mi avevano frenato fino ad allora è
un senso di libertà inappagabile è un
senso di libertà che che tutti vorremmo
provare è un vuoto stracolmo stracolmo
finalmente da tutte le nostre
convinzioni da tutte le nostre
riflessioni un voto stracolmo del
dell'aver creduto in noi stessi e allora
ecco oggi parliamo di coraggio delle
idee e io Io penso che portare avanti
con coraggio le proprie idee sia un
qualcosa di simile a ciò che si prova
quando si fa del bunging Jumping ci
vuole audacia ci vuole senso di
responsabilità ci vuole ecco riflessione
ci vuole molto amor proprio in politica
il coraggio di portare avanti le idee
dovrebbe esserne il motore Eppure mi
sono resa conto in questi anni da
europarlamentare che spesso in politica
manca il coraggio di portare avanti le
idee
prevale la convenienza prevale
l'opportunismo
il nostro agire spesso rischia di essere
orientato dai sondaggi dai social
network il politico rischia di essere
più appagato dal like che ha su Facebook
piuttosto che dalla gratificazione che
si ha nel seguire le idee in cui si
crede eppure vi dicevo che invece il
coraggio D D idee dovrebbe essere il
motore della politica e attenzione
perché quando parlo di coraggio delle
idee in politica non parlo del coraggio
del dell'esternalizzazione
[Musica]
difficili perché quello è il senso del
dovere è l'assumere delle responsabilità
e l'onor il mandato per il quale si è
stati eletti E per il quale si deve
governare o rappresentare i cittadini
che ci hanno mandato nelle istituzioni e
allora in politica il coraggio delle
idee
è credere in un'idea che in un
determinato momento storico può apparire
impopolare può sembrare che vada in una
direzione opposta a quella in cui va il
mainstream che va Ecco totalmente in un
altro senso Eppure Si si vuole avere il
coraggio di portare comunque avanti
quell'idea perché è un'idea che è stata
maturata È un'idea sulla quale abbiamo
riflettuto per la quale ci siamo
informati per la quale abbiamo studiato
ed è un'idea che siamo pronti a
difendere perché abbiamo gli strumenti
per farlo perché possiamo argar perché
possiamo motivare le nostre
posizioni perché possiamo rispondere a
critiche Questo è il coraggio delle idee
che dovrebbe ispirare sempre la politica
e io oggi voglio portarvi l'esempio di
tre persone tre storie di vita che hanno
in qualche modo ispirato il mio
agire il primo per me che sono
europarlamentare è l'esempio degli
esempi Rober
Schuman Schumann è considerato il padre
fondatore dell'Unione
Europea politico francese ministro degli
Esteri lui si presentò Nel
1950 ai giornalisti con la dichiarazione
divenuta poi famosissima C le berrima la
dichiarazione con la quale si invitavano
i paesi europei a cooperare a
collaborare e a mettere insieme gli
interessi economici Schuman insieme a
Jean Monet era convinto che mettendo
insieme gli interessi economici si
potesse garantire la pace Era il
1950 Quindi erano trascorsi 5 anni dalla
fine della Seconda Guerra Mondiale
c'erano ancora delle tensioni forti tra
Germania e Francia e l'unico modo per
garantire stabilità pace e cooperazione
tra i paesi dell'Unione Europea era
quello di far partire un progetto che
mettesse insieme inizialmente la
produzione del carbone e dell'acciaio e
e poi proseguirsi in un progetto più
ampio e che porta all'Unione Europea
quella che che conosciamo oggi un
progetto che come disse lo stesso
Schuman Nel 1950 è un progetto che non
si sarebbe fatto in una volta sola Ma
che si sarebbe costruito passo dopo
passo e ancora noi oggi lo stiamo
costruendo ancora noi oggi stiamo
contribuendo a far crescere il progetto
europeo a
migliorarlo Beh quando Schuman si
presentò Nel 1950 dei giornalisti
proponendo la nascita della dell'Unione
Europea la sua dichiarazione non fu
accolta unanimamente con grandissimo
entusiasmo c'era Chi vide in questa
dichiarazione come un patto tra i grandi
potenti tra i proprietari delle Miniere
e delle Industrie dell'acciaio c'era Chi
vide in questa dichiarazione una sorta
di di di dichiarazione di guerra a
blocco sovietico e c'era ancora chi
vedeva in questa
dichiarazione l'inizio dello sgrat
colamento
della dell'identità Nazionale perché
andare nella direzione del federalismo
avrebbe portato a depauperare l'identità
di ogni singolo paese discorsi non molto
dissimili da quelli che ancora oggi si
fanno dai interrogativi che ancora oggi
alcuni si pongono Eppure questo progetto
andò avanti fu attuato ripeto non è un
progetto già perfetto ma è un progetto
che ha cambiato lo scenario geopolitico
e ha cambiato soprattutto la vita di
delle nostre generazioni di quelle
passate e di quelle future perché ci ha
permesso di poter vivere in una
situazione di pace in una situazione in
cui ogni singolo cittadino ovunque si
trovi sul territorio comunitario si
sente come a casa propria Sa di poter
contare sulla stessa tutela di diritti
di libertà civile
di diritti civili di Diritti Sociali e
questa è una cosa che non bisogna mai
dare per scontato e per la quale bisogna
continuare sempre
a a lavorare e vi ho raccontato questo
esempio perché è l'esempio degli esempi
di come un'idea che in un determinato
momento storico può sembrare
rivoluzionario o comunque
inattuabile si può fare si può fare se
ci si
crede Se c'è la volontà di fare un
qualcosa si trova sempre un modo per
attuarla un secondo esempio che vi
voglio fare è quello della storia di
vita di Sofia Corradi Chi di voi conosce
Sofia Corradi ne ha mai sentito
parlare però se vi parlo di progetto
Erasmus Ecco il progetto Erasmus lo
conoscete tutti Ecco Sofia Corradi è
colei che ha ideato il progetto erasm
e eco lei che nel
1967 si
presentò con questa idea di creare un
progetto che garantisse
l'interculturalità e che si vide
rispondere un bel no si vide rifiutare
quel progetto e perché non era
realizzabile Sofia Corradi non si fece
scoraggiare lei aveva questo progetto in
mente perché aveva avuto l'opportunità
con una borsa di studio di studiare alla
Columbia University e quando poi era
rientrata in Italia voleva vedersi
riconosciuti tre esami Che le mancavano
per potersi laureare tre esami che lei
aveva già sostenuto a New York quando
però arrivò in Italia questi tre esami
non le furono convalidati Quindi lei
dovette ripeterli per poi potersi
laureare da lì avendo avuto L'esperienza
di potersi confrontare con tantissime
studentesse e tantissimi studenti che
arrivavano da ogni parte del mondo Ecco
cominciò a ideare questo progetto che
permettesse a tante persone di spostarsi
di poter avere delle esperienze di
studio e di vita non soltanto quindi nel
proprio paese di residenza Ma anche in
altri paesi europei e immagino che molti
di voi in sala qui abbiano già vissuto
queste esperienze abbiano fatto il
progetto Erasmus io stessa ho ho fatto
il progetto Erasmus molti continueranno
a farlo perché è un'esperienza di vita
altamente formativa che ti arricchisce
tanto Ebbene vi dicevo che Sofia Corradi
ricevesse un no nel
1967 quando presentò per la prima volta
il il progetto e non fu l'unico no che
ricevette Ci vollero 18 anni per poter
veder barato il progetto Erasmus da
parte dell'Unione Europea per 18 anni
Sofia Corradi continuò incant e
ostinatamente a portare avanti quella
sua idea idea a discutere con i rettori
a discutere con ministri con presidenti
di governo perché sapeva che quell'idea
era giusta andava perfezionata andava
migliorata ma andava attuata ed è quindi
un esempio di come con grande
determinazione con grande caparbietà ma
anche con impegno perché attenzione
quando ci si ostina in un'idea senza
rendersi conto che magari quell'idea va
perfezionata Si rischia di andare nella
direzione dell'opus sità e invece Ecco
con con umiltà con impegno con l'ascolto
e con il confronto quel progetto è stato
perfezionato e oggi molti giovani molte
studentesse e molti studenti hanno
potuto vivere questa
esperienza e poi l'ultima esperienza di
vita che vi voglio raccontare è quella
di
Paola Paola credo che sia seduta qui in
sala stasera è una donna un architetto e
una mamma molto coraggiosa molto forte è
mamma di un bambino autistico
e anche anche Paola ha raccolto il
coraggio a due mani non si è lasciata
abbattere e ha deciso di impegnarsi
molto per se stessa per il suo bambino
che oramai è un ragazzo e per tutti
coloro che come lei si sono
ritrovati inizialmente impreparati ad
affrontare una situazione così delicata
ad affrontare una disabilità che è forse
è più insidiosa delle altre perché che
rischia di isolare Chi ha CH è affetto
dall'autismo
che si si rinchiude nel proprio mondo ha
un proprio modo di comunicare rischia di
essere impenetrabile Ecco Paola è come
lei tante altre mamme e tanti altri papà
non si sono lasciati abbattere e hanno
deciso di impegnarsi in un'associazione
che aeme qui a Vibo ma anche a Cosenza
io autentico e come io autentico ci sono
diverse altre associazioni che si
occupano di persone affette da autismo e
il suo impegno consiste nell'attività di
divulgazione di sostegno di Cooperazione
e Ed è proprio un esempio da
seguire sia per tutti coloro che vivono
la stessa esperienza di Paola sia per
noi politici che abbiamo il dovere di
ascoltare di osservare di imparare e di
traslare tutto questo in normative
regionali nazionali o europee Ecco io vi
ho voluto riportare questi tre esempi
per dirvi quanto possano essere potenti
le idee quanto possa essere importante
perseguire un proprio obiettivo un
proprio progetto che dà un appagamento a
se stessi ma dà un miglioramento nella
qualità della vita a tutte le altre
persone e allora ognuno di noi ognuno di
voi può imprimere un cambiamento nella
storia Basta credere se stessi
[Musica]
Grazie